e niente tesoro da è che lasciava
sentiamo da borghesi per qualcuno che
rompe le palle set è tutto già ha
bisogno signora lei che numero 94 allora
solo quando chiama 94 e si può alzare
venire da me non mi interessa che
l'appuntamento due ore fa si vada a
sedere studio medico scanagatta signora
non ho capito niente un appuntamento col
dottor merluzzi sì allora la prima è
scritta che o il 24 giugno no signora
non di quest'anno del 2024 ovviamente
scusi un secondo lei la signora fa la
signora l'euro all'appuntamento alle
doti ci sono le 12 03 dottor è arrivata
la signora calanda con tre minuti di
ritardo niente signora se riesce la fa
passare oggi sono domani a dopodomani
lei rimanga lì sono d'attesa e vediamo
cosa succede la signora gliel'ho già
detto non c'è disponibilità il dottore
riceve a hong kong shangai nikkei è
sempre in ge la signora scusi un secondo
deve pagare sono 950 euro senza signora
mi faccia la cortesia ci chiarisca le
idee e poi magari mi richiamate quando
ho tempo da perdere